oui
deux amis un lapin et inserts mène une
vie paisible à fait de jeu est au taquet
concédant un objet mystérieux vient
troubler leur existence un cube
il découvre alors un monde nouveau où
les objets deviennent des volumes mais
comment fait-on pour rester amis quand
chacun se trouve dans un monde différent
cet automne vivez les aventures du lapin
et tu sers dans leur monde fabuleux et
découvrez tous leurs amis de pieuvre
lancer dans une incroyable course
poursuite
un petit chat qui rêve de devenir
chanteur
des poules dans la cour du roi coque
il ya même des girafes très forte
un plongeoir chromatique
les animaux faire pour lui